et puis le Président zelemski remercie à
l'instant Washington pour je cite son
indispensable aide à la défense de
l'Ukraine on en parle avec vous Paul
Valley bonsoir à vous vous êtes
historiens politologue et chercheur
associé au Centre de sécurité politique
de Genève et merci d'avoir accepté
l'invitation de France 24 Paul Valley
avant d'aborder ensemble les dangers
qu'on représente c'est bon bah à
soumission parce que c'est ce qui
retient essentiellement l'attention
j'aimerais qu'on comprenne ensemble quel
est l'avantage tactique sur le terrain
de telles armes
alors comme vous l'avez vu ce sont des
des bombes qui sont généralement largués
par air il y a aussi parfois des
versions des versions artillerie mais
principalement c'est une armée aérienne
qui a été d'ailleurs même développé dès
la seconde guerre mondiale il faut le
savoir donc c'est dans l'arsenal des
grandes puissances militaires depuis 3
générations et on le voit bah on a on a
développé bien sûr tout un bah toute une
gamme en fait de ces bombes qui se
fragmentent en plus petit explosifs
alors évidemment ce dont on auquel on
songe le plus souvent en relation
justement à la convention de 2008 qui a
qui s'est élevé contre ces contre ces
armes c'est celle qui répondent des
mines antipersonnelles et là évidemment
bien sûr on voit la filiation entre
cette convention et la convention de ta
pas sur l'interdiction des mines
antipersonnelles mais l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles justement plusieurs des
pays comme on l'a vu sur la carte n'ont
pas non plus ni signé ni ratifié cette
cette convention et c'est pas seulement
justement les États-Unis la Russie et
l'Ukraine on peut le voir sur la carte
la Chine le Brésil l'Inde le Pakistan
Israël quasiment tout le Moyen-Orient et
l'Afrique du Nord non pas ratifié cette
convention donc il y a effectivement une
croyance que ces armes offrent un
avantage tactique alors on en a parlé un
petit peu dans le dans le reportage ce
qui a été évoqué c'était à la fois la
capacité antipersonnelle et anti blindée
mais il semble aussi qu'on ait évoqué
ces derniers jours justement
l'utilisation de ces armes face aux très
grands champs de mines qui ont été
placés par les forces russes en avance
de digne de défense dans le sud et l'est
de l'Ukraine et ces armes pourraient
être utilisées pour des bombardements de
saturation sur des endroits en recherche
la percée
ok ok merci d'avoir terminé votre phrase
mais je voulais simplement apporter une
précision ces armes on le rappelle elles
sont déjà utilisées et par les
ukrainiens et par les Russes dans cette
guerre tout à fait ces documents ça a
été des le premier jour de l'invasion le
24 février 2022
ce qui interpelle c'est leur effet vous
le disiez tout à l'heure antichard
anti-personnel mais selon certains
spécialistes certains experts ils
expliquent qu'une fois cette bombe
larguée certaines grenades n'explosent
pas au moment de l'impact mais ça peut
se produire un petit peu plus tard d'où
le danger représenté pour les civils
c'est bien ça parfaitement et justement
ça a été le principal argumentaire qui a
été mis en avant par les promoteurs de
la convention de 2008 et
on a parlé de l'organisation Human Right
Watch qui a été justement l'une des
organisations internationales
particulièrement en pointe sur le
processus d'élaboration de négociation
et de promotion de cette convention tout
le problème effectivement c'est posé
pour les designers de ce genre d'armes
justement de réduire autant que possible
justement le le taux d'échec et il faut
savoir que dans la doctrine militaire
américaine même si les États-Unis n'ont
pas voulu ratifier cette convention il y
a une évolution qui est en cours depuis
donc la convention 2008 et
progressivement les États-Unis ont
réduit dans leur doctrine d'emploi
justement ces munitions en élevant des
conditions toujours plus strictes il
fallait ils essayaient d'avoir un taux
disons de non-explosion de moins de 1%
et ça ils ont pas réussi à 1% c'est
quand même une part infime de
de la part des munitions qui sont qui
sont larguées il faut savoir que selon
certains experts les munitions qui sont
utilisées par la Russie ont un taux de
non-explosion de 40%, on n'est pas du
tout dans la même échelle et plus élevé
vous évoquez à l'instant les États-Unis
on sait que Joe Biden était opposé dans
un premier temps à l'envoi de ces bombas
à munitions pourquoi est-ce qu'il a
changé d'avis selon vous est-ce que
c'est une alternative une sorte de plan
B au refus des avions de chasse des F1
notamment
alors manifestement il y a depuis
quelques jours justement des justement
une pression assez insistante qui émane
des des
chefs militaires et politiques
Ukrainiens par rapport justement aux
difficultés de trouver la percée et de
réaliser
réaliser des gains significatifs sur
leur offensive il y a aussi et alors ça
c'est pointé depuis l'hiver dernier un
épuisement des munitions d'artillerie
classique
y compris les familles weimark qui sont
qui ont été utilisés pour des frappes à
longue portée et comme on dit justement
les Ukrainiens sont maintenant vraiment
confrontés face à ces lignes de défense
qui leur pose gros problème
on sait justement que il y a eu lenteur
de décision sur la fourniture de d'avion
qui aurait donné aux Ukrainiens à un
certain avantage
au moins pour la la crise du ciel sur
l'espace de bataille
il y a effectivement les lenteurs de
fournitures donc de ces munitions de
blindées lourds
effectivement ça a pris ça a sûrement
été une décision assez complexe pour Joe
Biden mais il l'a prise là et il sait
qu'il s'expose évidemment à un certain
aimant de critique faut savoir
évidemment que seul baiten avait
l'autorité politique nécessaire pour
prendre cette décision et réviser ce qui
était la politique officielle américaine
de nouveaux fournitures à des pays tiers
de ces munitions est-ce que c'est aussi
parce que c'est le bon moment si l'on si
l'on se fie aux déclarations de
l'état-major ukrainien qui explique que
les troupes avancent pas à pas
progressivement certains villages sont
repris la bataille continue notamment
autour de barmouth en ça mais ce qu'il
faut frapper maintenant si vous me
passez l'expression
évidemment les les forces ukrainiennes
ont envie justement de poursuivre dans
ce momentum et de réaliser justement des
dégâts significatifs c'est un c'est un
souci qui est à la fois militaire et
politique pour eux parce que ils savent
aussi que un enlisement et un arrêt de
la de la contre-offensive serait assez
sévèrement jugé
à la fois dans leur pays mais aussi bien
sûr par les partenaires alliés donc il y
a vraiment un besoin de pouvoir
justement marquer des points si on peut
se remettre l'expression dans ce
contexte mais bien sûr c'est un pari
risqué et bien sûr cette seule arme ne
peut pas être la solution magique
évidemment à de meilleures performances
sur le front et ben moi si vous le
voulez bien Paul Valley est-ce que parce
que la précision du calendrier n'a pas
été annoncée est-ce qu'on sait dans ces
armes peuvent être livrés alors pour
l'instant c'est assez difficile à
déterminer on le sait avec toutes les
autres types d'armes de munitions qu'on
dû être fournies à l'Ukraine ça a
toujours entraîné
presque dans tous les cas effectivement
des certains délais
c'est difficile à dire on ne verrait
probablement pas un usage très massif de
ces armes je veux dire dans les jours
prochains ça va prendre un petit peu de
temps aussi bien sûr pour pour les
Ukrainiens voir comment ils arrivent à
sur quel vecteurs ils arrivent à monter
ces munitions merci beaucoup le valet
merci d'avoir pris le temps de répondre
à nos questions